here this afternoon for the tampa bay
rays is going to be right-hander shane
boss this is his line retired 15 of the
17 batters he faced the two hits were
two solo home runs didn't walk anybody
don't think that he got to a three-ball
count pounded the zone with the fastball
and slider and as we talked in the open
the confidence in which he conducted
himself i guess you could say on that
mound tons of confidence for a young
pitcher making his major league debut
you're always looking for those emotions
he didn't seem to show anybody or show
any and that's going up against one of
the top offenses in the game so shane
bob's looking to build off that here
this afternoon
and a cut to miss he strikes out
chisholm pulled the string how about it
i'll tell you that looked just like the
heater except it was minus about 10
miles an hour there it is that is a
thing of beauty you team that pitch up
with the fastball that can be so
explosive and then you think about the
slider the curveball on top of that
there is a lot to like
and he is out on strikes missed the
breaking pitch two up two down
well that was the change-up version of
the breaking balls he's gonna go with
the curveball here 82 miles an hour and
just rolls it down and away
right off the plate getting the chase
there it is the knuckle curve
beautifully located 3-2
and he got it 98 up how about that a
couple of change-ups behind
up there with 98 to strike him out one
two three strikes out the side against
jesus luzado 17th start 24th game this
season and 11th with the marlins
there's a pitch to low ball four margot
with the lead off walk bronco at 284
that's a lighter into left field
that ball is going to bound off the wall
extra bases margot will go to third
that's a double for franco and the rays
have an immediate threat here in the
first inning as franco extends the
on-base street to 41. wander on base for
the 41st consecutive game good to get
that out of the way too you bet too shy
of frank robinson for all time on base
for a player 20 years or younger and
here's nelson cruz
live off center field ella cruz
mainly to his left to make the catch tag
at both second and third margot will
score franco goes to third and the rays
lead one-nothing that'll send up yondi
diaz
high five ball deep into right sanchez
back to the track will turn around to
make the catch tag at third broncos
gonna score and the rays have a
two-nothing lead yandy diaz got the
extended advantage drives in the run
and a strikeout of luplow but the rays
get a couple in the first inning now
nick fortes
swinton gets a miss the breaking ball
takes care of fortes one two three go to
marlins
cisco
2-2 pitch a late swing and a miss he
tried to stay back on the offspring
pitch looking fastball couldn't adjust
mejia strikes out to two k's now for
lizardo and here's the thing with los
arto gotta finish this inning start it
off good you've got first two out you
have to be able to go ahead and put it
away it would be a very nice bounce back
inning after his first inning
away we go and back-to-back strikeouts
here for luzardo he works a
one-two-three second good bounce back
next that's eddie alvarez
swinging again
alvarez out on strikes he missed 98
three strikeouts in the first strikeout
on a breaking ball in the second and now
98 here in the third
and there is strike three call 98
on the outside corner we go to the
bottom of inning three nelson cruz
he got cruz to chase strikeout number
four for luzardo back to back one two
three innings
that fastball takes care of diaz
what do you do with that pitch
2-2 pitch
and he drops that breaking ball that
curveball in there for a strike three
called that's a dandy well do you
remember the swing on that curveball
he's like i'm not doing that again i'm
just going to hope that it's a ball
high fly ball back into left
rows
just at the track makes the catch no
runs a hit one left wander franco
that's a base hit into left center field
gonna roll to the wall extra base is
coming for franco he's around second
already digging for three he's gonna
make it easily fifth triple of the year
for franco nelson cruz man the third two
out
hey there's a line drive base hit the
reigns have another run bronco scores on
the base hit by nelson cruz and the rays
make it a three-round lead alex jackson
lead things off
swing and a miss boy he takes care of
jackson again on three pitches got him
looking on the fastball in the third
nine strikeouts on the day for boz one
away here's jazz
3-1 to jazz
there's a base hit up the middle
and jazz takes a big turnaround first on
his way to second with a hustle double
and instep say zu sanchez
and that one gets by mejia jazz led to
third on the wild pitch
a pie for ball four first walk allowed
by boz and out comes kevin cash the
raids have the bullpen ready that's
gonna be it for shane baz
jt chagwal will be the new pitcher
making his 23rd appearance
brunson chops it to short
franco with the throw and it's scooped
over there by luke lowe so the rays get
out of that one on one pitch bring up
joe panic
and down the left field line a fair ball
it's gonna one hop up and over the wall
so joe panic with a multi-hit afternoon
so now here comes eddie alvarez with a
runner at second base and two outs in
the seventh trailing three nothing
eddie down the right field line that's a
fair ball and it uh one hops over the
wall so look at that marlins go line to
line back to back doubles and it's three
to one hey i kind of felt like eddie was
starting to come around a little bit his
last time up nearly hit one out to left
really just attacked layman with nothing
but fastballs well hopefully lewin can
sit on one here three and two from
anderson
he does and he hits this one high and
deep right center field and on cue
leigh diaz with a solo home run and the
marlins are down a run in the night now
quite predictably got another fastball
and lewin did not miss it unloads to
deep right field this is a one run ball
game
marlins are down to their final out a
couple of nice at bats his last two
times up
and a pop-up but a broken bat down from
first that's going to be caught
by joy and the raise went it it's a 3-2
final the raves win their 97th game of
the year and they go a club record 38
games over 500 97 wins tying the
franchise record for victories files
will get the win in his second start he
is 2-0
you